Hi. I'm Sara, a data
science educator at Posit.
In this video, I'll give you
a brief tour of Positron,
Posit's next-generation
data science IDE.
Positron is designed specifically
for doing data science.
It combines a modern coding
environment with tools tailored
for working with data.
Positron supports both R and
Python and makes it easy to
switch between the languages.
If you've used
RStudio or VS Code,
you'll notice some
familiar elements.
Positron is informed by our
experience building RStudio and
is a fork of VS Code.
You can download Positron
for Mac, Windows,
or Linux on the
Positron website.
Next, let's take a look at some
of Positron's key features.
When you first open up Positron,
it'll look something like this.
The first step is
to open a folder.
You can either open an existing
folder or a new folder.
Opening a folder will create a
workspace and set the working
directory similar to opening
up a project in our studio.
I'm going to open
an existing folder.
Let's take a look at
the layout of Positron.
All the way in the
left hand side,
the activity bar gives access
to features like the file
explorer, Peloton
assistant, and extensions.
Primary sidebar changes
depending on what you've
selected in the activity bar.
So right now, it's showing our files
because we have the file explorer selected.
In the center, we have the
editor where we write our code.
At the bottom, you can find
the console and the terminal.
And over on the right hand side,
you have the secondary sidebar.
This is where
plots will show up,
where we see our
loaded variables,
explore database connections,
and look at documentation.
Oswitron supports multiple
R and Python interpreters.
The active interpreter is shown over
here in the upper right hand corner.
You can click on the
interpreter picker to switch
between R and Python or
between R and Python versions.
You'll notice that
when I selected R,
the console is now an R console.
You can also switch between
languages or versions in the console.
The active interpreter
will be highlighted.
Loaded variables will show up in the
variables pane on the right hand side.
You can inspect variables
by expanding them.
For data frames, you'll
notice this table icon.
Clicking on that will
launch the data explorer,
which gives you a spreadsheet
style view of the data.
You can use the Data Explorer to get
a high level overview of your data.
You can see the distribution of
values in each of the columns
as well as filter by condition.
You can also sort
by a column and view
missing data percentages and
summary statistics all without
writing additional code.
Positron Assistant is an
AI tool that provides LLM
integration within Positron.
You can access Positron
Assistant from the activity bar.
Use Positron Assistant
to generate code, debug,
or get suggestions
for next steps. Positron
Assistant can
access context
from the console, variables
pane, and plots pane.
But you can also manually
attach files or folders to give
it additional context.
Positron Assistant
has three chat modes.
Ask, Edit, and Agent.
Use ask mode when you
want to ask questions,
get help with debugging, or
use Assistant to generate code.
For example, we could ask it what
we should do in our analysis of the
diamonds data.
It can reference our Quarto
document and see what we've
already done and
suggest next steps.
On edit mode, Assistant
will suggest code changes.
So let's say I have another
file and I'm getting an error.
On edit mode, I can ask Positron
Assistant to help fix the problem.
And notice that it now knows that
read diamonds.py is the current file.
Assistant identifies the issue
and supplies a fix that
I can accept or undo.
On agent mode,
Assistant can figure out the
next steps needed for your
request and autonomously
carry out those steps.
On your behalf, Positron Assistant
could execute code in the console,
create and modify files,
and identify the next steps based on
the results of the previous steps.
For example, we could ask it to move
this code that's in read diamonds
dot pi into a new Quarto file.
Positron Assistant creates a
new Quarto document and moves
my code over.
Note that Positron Assistant
is currently a preview feature.
Just like in RStudio,
you can pull up documentation
for our Python functions
directly within the IDE.
For either our Python,
you can either use
question mark
or help.
Pull up the documentation
in the help pane.
You can also use F1 key.
This allows you to easily
reference documentation without
leaving Positron.
There's a lot more you
can do with Positron,
but I hope this gave you a
sense of what's possible.
Use the following link to
download positron and get started.